Okay Dr. Bell, if you would please introduce yourself to your name in today's date in our location.
Um, David Bell, and today is July 9th.
July 9th.
Okay, July 9th, 2014, and we're located at my place on the Portrait of Olymp cabin.
Terrific.
Let's start at the beginning.
You were born in Grinch, Connecticut.
Grinch, Connecticut.
Grinch, Connecticut, 1938.
And were you raised there?
I was raised there pretty much, you know, for my whole life until I went to college.
Can you tell us about sort of your experience of Grinch growing up?
Well, Grinch is an interesting place.
It's a powerful place.
A lot of millionaires, we weren't one of them.
My dad was principal at high school.
And I went to the same high school.
And I think I really learned about leadership.
He was very good.
He said, if you spend more than 50% of your time in your office, you're not doing your job.
So as a student, he knew what was going on.
I was amazed.
None of the students ever gave me any hassle.
They said he was tough, but he's fair.
And he learned all sorts of things.
And he did this by getting down to the trenches.
I mean, he'd go down the border of the room and just talk with the maintenance people.
He talked with the people serving up floating in cafeteria.
And he wouldn't ask him for anything.
They would just tell him because they were part of the team.
So I learned that kind of leadership from him.
Unfortunately, we don't see that kind very often.
What were your parents' backgrounds?
My dad was a physicist.
I went to Yale.
He became a high school principal and a physical physics teacher.
And my mother was a pianist.
The concert pianist, she died when I was four.
But I can still remember sitting under the piano while she practiced.
And we did quite a bit of camping.
My dad ran a summer camps for churches, Lutheran Church.
And I learned a lot about nature then and the respect of nature from these big camps.
And they had a lot of these.
And their idea for helping kids was to get them into nature.
And that's what they did.
So I had that background.
And my beginning of environmental concerns came out of the church background in these summer camps.
I had three sisters and older sisters and two younger sisters.
How was the household managed after your mother passed?
Well, my father remarried several times.
I just treated him as a normal household.
He was a very good mentor and he had male friends who ran these summer camps.
And I had an anologa who was, she was quite a doer.
I never thought that women couldn't do anything men could do because my anologa obviously could.
So it just, you know, just never occurred to me.
So that was household.
We lived sort of in the country, not quite like this.
But spent a lot of time outdoors.
That was good.
What were your interest as a boy besides being outdoors, I suppose?
Outdoors, building tree huts.
I guess that was it.
I mean, I'm playing sports, but not, you know, not really that much.
So just hanging around outdoors and doing stuff, I guess.
Did you enjoy school?
Yeah, I enjoyed it.
I was not particularly in high school a great student.
Like most kids at age, I enjoyed seeing my friends and seeing my friends.
That's what I did.
What were your first inclinations towards science or engineering?
Oh, I don't know.
I think I was always, I want to do something.
And so I don't think I really, I mean, I was pretty good at science.
It was interesting.
And engineering seemed more like you were going to do something.
So I just sort of, it wasn't any big decision.
I did decide to go to the Virginia Military Institute, which anybody knows is a pretty tough place to go, particularly that first year you're rat.
Well, take me through the process of making that decision. Why VMI?
Well, VMI, like I say, it's tough.
I looked around a lot, you know, when you're growing up, kids, boys, at least.
What's a matter? Can't you take it? They place sort of those games.
And you think, well, when I get older, I don't have to play those games.
It's like getting, it's like I got older though.
I saw a lot of men were playing those games.
Same thing. I mean, I see it all the time at Oregon State University.
People getting co-opted and afraid to speak up.
So I said, I'm just going to go there.
Then, you know, it's tough.
And if anybody says, what's the matter? Can't you take it? I'll just laugh at them.
You go through the rat line. It's pretty tough.
So I think that was the way I thought of it.
And it generally worked that way. It was tough.
And you saw it as a challenge that you wanted to take on?
It was a challenge, that's right. And I saw it as a challenge to take on.
And I wasn't planning career military. I wasn't looking for a disciplined life.
It was a challenge. And I think VMI nurtured that.
You always had a maverick spirit, very rigid, tough discipline, but there was always.
There was a tension there, a creative tension.
And so I thought of the word challenge as a positive word.
And something's challenging. My eyes light up. Oh, okay. What are we going to do about it?
So, and it was a good education. Class sizes were about 2022.
And I had some pretty remarkable people there.
Jonathan Daniels was a martyr in the Civil Rights Movement.
And he was a seminary student when he left VMI.
He became an episcopal priest and he got killed there.
That really jolted the South, unfortunately.
You know, Jonathan had to give his life for it.
But he was quite a person. He's a valedictorian of our class.
Well, what was the environment like at VMI especially that first year?
Oh, that first year you were a rat. That first year and you're on the go all the time.
It's physically and mentally demanding. It's psychologically demanding.
But all your classmates are in the same boat. So it's not like they're picking on you.
I mean, you're all in it together. And there are times of anus.
You say, well, they can't kill me. And this isn't going to last forever.
Somehow that that would get you through. And I thought of that years later in terms of racial prejudice.
Because people can't say that. They couldn't say that.
And when I went back to one of my reunions, one of the most impressive things that happened to me.
There was an older guy there that was a maintenance person.
And he was black. And I told him what year I was there.
And I think he says, oh, that's when he began. And he comes in. He gives me this big hug.
And we're celebrating together. And it felt really good. It really did.
And they've integrated down there because it was not integrated when I went there.
And they've done a really good job. And there's men and women down there now.
So not integrated as in it was whites only. Or there were white classes and black classes.
And it was almost all white. I think it probably was all white.
And just in a South that, you know, as people just didn't even think of it.
And Jonathan did. He gave his life for it.
Well, when they decided, when they, at VMI, when they figured, this is a serious problem, they really set out to correct it.
And they really did. And we've had some remarkable graduates white and black and patient.
So it was, it was really, you know, I would say turning point in my life, I mean, to see that change is wonderful.
What else was expected of students there besides the coursework?
Well, you had physically demanding. And of course, you're first year, you're harassed.
I mean, you're in the rat line, you're a rat. And you're on the go all the time.
And so it's hard to describe. I mean, the Marines respected.
And I've had several Marines say, yeah, it's tough. And for a Marine, that's probably about the best compliment you can get.
And it's mutual. I mean, yeah.
So a lot of physical training and military drilling ice didn't work?
Well, there's not, not a particularly a lot of drilling. You had to raise that you did and you marched and you wore uniforms.
But the academics were very good. And classes were small. And they were, you know, they were academically very good.
So it's just tough schedule. And physically demanding. I mean, if you've got a chance to take a nap, you'd lay down for 15 minutes and go to sleep and wake up and start all over again.
But during the day, you didn't even have your beds down. I mean, you rolled up the mattresses. They were up against, you know, rolled up.
And they called it a hay rack. That was leaned against the wall. I mean, it was, it was pretty rigid.
But it always had sort of a maverick spirit to it. You know, one night we tried it. We put the evening gun and said, I don't know, 90 millimeter howitzer in the PX, you know, snuck out there.
I mean, there'd be things you'd sort of do that way. And things, things would happen.
So it was, you learn some things like pulling rank. That's really bad. I mean, if you, somebody does something, yeah, you got rank. Of course, you know, a dean or president has to do things. They have responsibility. We all know that.
But if they do something and it's only because I got the rank, that's point rank. And that's not looked on pretty well. In fact, they'd have a parade in the parade. There'd be a flanking movement. The troops are companies, the tones are going on the line.
And the officer was a kid at officer, but being the front with a saber marching in the front. And there would be tack officers grading the lines. Well, if he had pulled rank, those lines would just go like this. And then he'd get chewed out. So they, you know, if you pulled rank, we throw lines.
So I mean, it was, it was just pulling rank was not, not considered a particularly good thing. I see more of it going on at Oregon State University. And people sort of accepting it. That's the part that drives me nuts.
You know, someone says something does something that doesn't make sense. People like and courteous, but tell them a lot of times they, you know, they may get upset, but they, they're really the best ones. No, they need to hear that.
But I've seen just too many people with this blank face. Just don't say anything.
So how your academic life sort of evolved while you're at the MI?
Well, I actually got better grades at college than I did in high school. And I ended up with a civil engineering degree.
And I don't know whether I had any career aspirations of that. It was like you're entering a big open space. You're entering the future.
So I didn't have an agenda what I wanted to do, what I wanted to be. I wanted to do something, do something interesting. I was more scout, I sort of explore.
So I guess, and I think at the MI they encouraged that you'd ask questions in class. And I thought it was a good education that way. I know we're bad teachers. Yeah, but you always are. But you learn from them too.
Well, you took that education your first job was with the division of Indian health. Yeah, US Public Health Service. Right. US Public Health Service Indian Health. And I went to New Mexico and loved it.
And it was a sanitary engineer they called them. And we put in water and sewer systems and Indian club blows. And I bring in translators. And then I got transferred to a state of Washington. And it was kind of funny because they said, well, there's a project that has a little bit of a problem.
Any time a government agency says we have a little bit of a problem, that means it's a disaster. So when I got up there, the project engineer wasn't even there. And turns out that some woman had punched him out. And after listening to the stories, I began to understand why.
But you know, we got the project lined up. But even there, there were some things, you know, you had to do like they didn't have enough parts to keep the crews busy.
Well, if you look at the government procedures, it takes months to get the parts. Your budget's going to be gone or you have to lay off the crew.
And so I just went out and told them wrote a memo and said, I'm going to go and buy some parts wholesale. And if this is a problem, please call me. And then I stayed away from the phone. So I got the parts.
You know, and they were upset because they probably could have saved $30 by going through the GAO or no GSA. But, you know, the loss of money for the crew.
So I mean, you did things like that. I loved the crew. I loved the construction. A lot of funny stories they tell me and had a good time. It was good.
What sort of impacted living in Indian country make, idea?
Well, I actually, in Albuquerque, I was living in Albuquerque and I go on the reservation. And in the state of Washington, I didn't, you know, I live off reservation. But it was more in the state of Washington, more like rural country.
And I love the culture, I love the dances. And it was a really good experience for me. So I sort of participated. I even broke my wrist riding rodeo. So I had a little bit of, you know, some good stories to tell. So that was good.
What did you think of the Pacific Northwest? I've seen that was your first exposure to it.
Yeah. And I only, I was up in the state of Washington. And I did drive through Oregon and then went over to the coast and the thing that impressed me, the coast was, it was hard to get down to the beach. There were so many logs. I mean, there were just logs all over the place.
And, and of course, now there aren't. And I think there were a lot of wasteful timber practices back then and long to just drift out.
But so I really didn't, I didn't, you know, I was in Eastern Washington. And so it's quite different than Corvallis. I mean, I liked, I liked beautiful country.
Well, after a year or two, I think with that job, you went back to school.
Yeah, I spent a little over a year or two years in public health service. And I went back to New York University, right in the middle of New York City. What had changed?
I mean, holy mackerel, I'm out in the, you know, out in the sticks and my arms and a cast, my rodeo accident. I'm ending up ending up in New York, middle of New York City.
But I did get a good education there at New York University. And I got into computer modeling. And this was back in the mid 60s.
So I got into that for Tran was pretty new then. And I did sort of learn machine language, which was awful for Tran, though this was great.
I had a very good major professor and I got into computer simulation long before most people.
There were no PCs back then. There was no internet. I used to take cards down on the subway to the Greenwich Village. That's where the Quran Institute of Mathematics was.
And they had a big computer then you'd give them the cards and they'd run it. And then you'd plot by hand the results.
But you got to understand what a model does because you plot them by hand, you did them yourself. You could actually see what was going on in the computer.
And now a lot of people don't see that. They really don't understand that. And consequently, I think there's a lot of misuse of computer models now.
That's what the things were you modeling.
Lakes and estuaries. And the thing about estuaries is they're part of the river that's influenced by the ocean. And the tides come in and out.
They're very dynamic systems of waters changing. And so before the digital computer, you had to make mathematical assumptions of steady state.
And the sanitary engineers have been doing this since 1925. And rivers building mathematical models long before the scientists were doing it.
And actually the rivers got better. They did a lot. There was a lot of good. And that's sort of been airbrushed out of the history.
We may come back to that later because there was a lot of environmental improvements on rivers in particular that occurred there. And I was part of that history.
But the 60s things were changing. We knew things were changing. We saw lakes were having problems. We saw all sorts of problems.
And so that was a real era of transformation when I got here. The computer and a pretty exciting time.
Was this also your first experience of teaching?
Yeah, my first experience in teaching formally. I used to do some help sessions for some of my classmates back at the M.I.
And my family has a lot of teachers. And so I loved it. So I had, you know, I loved the students and teaching. And I like the research.
I don't like proposal writing. We'll come back to that later.
Tell me about living in New York City in the 60s.
Well, you know, I was mainly involved in graduate school. And there was some protests. I generally was not part of that.
But my part of the protest, I was part of, in a sense, of let's do something about the problems.
And mainly pollution. And certainly Martin Luther King Jr. had a profound effect on me. This is a huge transformation.
And it was, that was a good time. I think that what happened a little bit after that, the drug scene and other things.
I felt like that was very different, very self-indulgent and often destructive.
So I really, I had a mixed feelings. I really identified, yes, let's make the world a better place.
But there also seemed to be sort of self-centered naiveness that was associated with this.
And maybe a tendency to blame other people rather than saying what can we do.
So I had a mix, it was a mixed feeling, mixed bang.
Was this, is it fair to say this was sort of the beginnings of your environmental consciousness that come before?
Oh, environmental consciousness came before, came largely through the churches. And again, that's been a whole history that they don't talk about.
You probably have read that. You probably took the history of environmental from Bob McDermott.
And that's just not included. Well, it was huge. I mean, here my father would have 300 boys out in this cabins out there.
And they have nature counselors. And across the river was a lake, was a girls camp.
And then there was another teenage camp, young adults camp there. And this was a big thing.
And so I was always taught that respect. And there was also sort of a technology.
Well, it's got some good things, but it's got some limitations too. So we also had that.
And when I got here at Oregon State University, it was the campus ministries that were challenging higher education.
There's a guy John Connor, you ought to just do a separate history on John Connor.
And because he probably did more to change Oregon State University than any other person here. He was a campus minister at Westminster House.
And we would have classes there and on environmental problems and appropriate technology was a big thing.
And there were some economics theories. Kenneth Bolding and Herman Daley, Dick Clinton, if you interview him, he'll tell you about Herman Daley.
And academia just sort of closed that stuff off.
And at the time in the late 60s and early 70s, it was pretty exciting.
There was a lot of interesting things that were happening. But that movement died out.
And again, it's sort of been airbrushed out of the history. And I think this is one of the things that's probably important for oral history.
Because a lot of historians, they study the archives. Well, the stuff that may be most important didn't make it into the archives.
Because the big institutions basically don't fund that. And so it sort of disappears.
So we need to have people take oral history and say, look, here's some good stuff.
And it makes a lot of sense. Kenneth Bolding, Herman Daley.
I mean, you go back, E.F. Schumacher, small as beautiful. I mean, these were books that came in books of writings and speeches that were amazing.
Kenneth Bolding is one of the best speakers I heard on an economist. And he studied terribly.
And you'd sit there and you'd first be nervous. And then you'd realize that it doesn't bother him. So it didn't bother you.
It was amazing. And it came up with some really good stuff. I think if we were to know how to deal with some of the environmental problems we have now, go back and look at them.
And Kenneth Bolding was a quaker. Herman Daley, I think, was a Methodist, E.F. Schumacher, Catholic.
This was a spiritual movement, but it was, it was certain, it had nothing to do with intelligent design or evolution or anything like that.
It was never an issue. And so that's a part of the history. If people want to understand where we're at now, I think, you can go back and say there were some opportunities that were missed that happened.
I'll come back to some of those.
Well, tell me about the decision to come to OSU in 1967. You'd graduated from NYU and you came here.
Yeah, I don't think I singled out OSU for any reason. In fact, I had applied to EPA. And they were going to hire me. And Tom Baumgartner was over EPA.
And the hire me on beautification, study of lakes. And also, the story. Tom was a story. Anyhow, aquatic ecosystems.
And somehow that position fell through. So he sent my resume over to Fred Burgers, who was the Dean of Engineering.
And I got this notice. You know, would you like a position here? So I said, yeah. So I took it.
What was your first impression of the university and of the town?
Well, I liked it. I really, you know, it's a beautiful campus. And it still is. I mean, it's, I mean, it has a few ugly beliefs.
I mean, generally, I think it's a fantastic campus. The people were good, friendly. So I enjoyed it.
What was the department like?
The department was a good department. It was a traditional engineering department. But I did have some, some certain amount of freedom.
I started a course on mathematical modeling, computer simulation. And you look back. And that was a pretty big jump for a lot of the people back then.
Because the digital computer was fairly new, except the military, of course. And so I had a course there.
I also had a course, a graduate course got on the books that was something like a philosophy of technology.
So they, you know, they were receptive to this. And I think my education and VMI helped a little bit because, you know, if I felt strongly about something, I told them so.
And I think most people appreciated that. At least they knew that I wasn't going to back off because I was afraid of raising something unusual. They didn't even occur to me.
So I did get some courses taught then. And at that time, I had the mightest touch. I could get research grants. I mean, I was just, you know, I couldn't believe it.
Now they weren't big grants like you get now. I had, I had, on estuaries, I had one. And then I had, you know, a multiplication as it lakes. What happens to lakes? It was a computer simulation. And I got that.
And I had another interesting one. And we'll talk a little more about that. And that was environmental strategies under indeterminacy. I think that's what the title was. And they even funded that one. It was a small grant.
But then the strange things happened. As my awareness started to expand, the funding agency started to go narrower.
And by the end of the 70s, things have changed. Things have really changed. What do you think happened?
Well, that's a good story. And that's the one the historians have to look at. Now there are some historians here.
Army Mother Nature, Jacob Darwin, Hamlin, great name, Jacob Darwin, I love it. He's written a very good book. And it's about how the environmental movement or the environmental science more, environmental science.
Particularly big computer models came out of the military. And I didn't know that at that time. But my background was out of the sanitary engineering.
So it was a whole different background. And what happened is their way of doing it took over. And the way we were doing it shrunk.
And so what they were saying is, well, we'll build big computer models. I'm simplifying it.
And that's how we'll approach the future. Well, I was in a computer model. And I said, you can't do, I mean, yeah, build computer models.
But you cannot have environmental strategies based on prediction and control. The world is too complex.
And so what we did during this study, what I did during this study, environmental strategies under indeterminacy.
I said, look, we have a strategy. It's very simple. You don't need big models. You could build big models, but you need a strategy. And the strategy is we will make mistakes.
Okay, that's called confession. Okay. And so what you have to do is learn how to make good mistakes. And a good mistake is, say, reversible.
Good mistakes are ones you learn from. Good mistakes are ones where you don't get painted in a box. So we came up with a strategy like this.
And it all made very good sense. And it does to this day. I mean, you take carbon dioxide, the greenhouse war.
People still trying to predict their models are all over the place if you go far out. But the CO2 impact is almost irreversible. And it's just shooting through the sky.
So under that strategy, we would have said, you got to stop. You can't wait till you find out what the impacts are. It's too late. The world is changing faster than you can develop your predictions.
So I thought it all made sense. So they send, when I write my file report in 78, and I got a copy of it.
They send the guy out there to look over my shoulder while I'm writing it. This is strange. That never happened before.
And I thought maybe it was because when the Senator Proxmire is Golden Fleece Awards, he would ridicule scientific projects.
But I realize now after some of the history books coming out, the paradigms were changing. They were saying we want big scale computer models. And I was in the modeling booth.
So the guy looked over my shoulder and said, okay. And I thought he was pleased with the report. When he was. But when he left, he said, we'll never fund anything like this again.
I go, why? I was shocked. We don't have a box to put it in. This is the answer. Now I didn't realize at that time that that's what the transformation was occurring.
You're building big boxes. So you have all these little specialized areas to do certain tasks to fit into the models.
And we weren't looking at this. Now one of the guys I worked with on here is Scott Overton. Did you interview Scott? No. It's a shame. He passed away.
But there is a website. You really ought to take a look at it. Very impressive guy. And Scott and I probably at Oregon State between the two of us at the time.
We published a paper in 72. We probably had more environmental computer modeling than any other to it in the university.
And we basically came up with a strategy that was not based on prediction and control. And avoid large scale irreversible change.
You have to do that because you don't know what the consequences are. Be so when you make a mistake, you want to make a good mistake, which means you can reverse it.
CO2 doesn't reverse. I mean, it's up there for centuries. It's sad.
Tell me about Overton. Overton, Scott Overton, statistics and forest management. And Scott, he was very disciplined. In fact, there were people in statistics. I think they were afraid of him.
And a good guy. Very thoughtful person. Very rigorous. Very rigorous. And he was a few years old in my I was. He was a scouting war work too, I think.
And how you can look up his background and statistics and forest management. And he just was good. So we got together and we started talking about this.
We said, let's write a paper on it. And it was published in the American Society Civil Engineers, sanitary engineering division. It really wasn't.
The environmental science was his sort of, well, was it really out there? Scott had a student, Larry Hunt. And I think early 70s he did his PhD. And he had to do it in forest management. There was no ecology. But it was in ecology, you know, PhD.
We had a graduate faculty of ecology. We were sort of fighting the system. And during his one of his last meetings in marches of group of faculty from forest management, complaining that he didn't take the road design courses and the cable design all the stuff about logging.
And well, he had a powerful committee and there was a dean of forestry. I think his name was Stonebird. And I have to give the guy credit. He picked up the body language of our committee that we were going to fight for this guy. And so he was very diplomatic, but he says, well, this time, we'll arrange this. So we got him through. So Larry Hunt was probably one of the first ones to actually get a PhD in ecology.
So there were other people who had done things in biology, but it was generally, it's not like it is now. So that was interesting.
I'm interested in knowing a little bit more about the climate on campus in the late 60s. Obviously was raging. There was a lot of tumult nationwide. What was your sense of the environment on campus itself?
I don't think I think relative to other places there was probably less. But I think some of the inquiry sort of maybe lasted a little longer. So it's like some other places burn out quicker.
My contact was largely through the campus ministries. And they were really they were really active all the way into the 70s. In fact, even beyond that.
I can remember having a course over in Westminster House. And so I knew the current of the ROTC, Kurt Rosler, I think, was his name. And he, I know this probably late 70s, I'm guessing.
And I may have the date off, but you can look up his pictures up there. And he was a tank commander. And so this is the Cold War. And during the Cold War, the Soviet tanks were, you know, I mean, the armed divisions, they were powerful. This was a major concern.
So I brought him over to one of these classes. And there were a whole lot of what we called hippies. And in this class, and he just wore sweater casual to billion clothes. And he started talking with them. And they didn't want to like him. But they did.
He was a good guy. And I remember asking him the question, what is more danger to American society? The Soviet tank or the American gas goes in the car. And he said, oh, that's easy. It's the car. And so I mean, we had those kinds of discussions that were going on.
They sort of ended late 80s. We put on a conference on Eisenhower's farewell address. He warns about the military industrial complex. But people don't realize he also warned about the university.
The danger is that the pursuit of government grants and contracts will be pursued so much that intellectual curiosity will be given up.
We must guard against scientific technological lead. And then later after that, he says only uninformed and knowledgeable citizenry can can prevent this from happening. I mean, he has some powerful stuff. So we did a whole conference on that.
And one of the things we did in that conference, Craig Walker, you can interview him. He's still there. He's got, he gave you a copy of the book. We did on it. He and I wrote a chapter at the end. And we said, suppose George Bush gave this con.
Because George Bush, the first George Bush was president then. And not George W. It was his George W's father. And so what we did is we took portions of the speech. And we just said, suppose George Bush wrote this.
And the only thing will change is his warning is not about the military industrial complex is the oil industrial complex. And so we changed. And it's really a radical. It comes across really radical. Well, you can take that and take it for his son. You can take it and give that speech now. And he was warning. I mean, is it remarkable with Eisenhower's whole life was in the military industrial complex.
And his final warning is warning about it. I was very impressed with that. And your sense was always you was falling prey to these warnings.
Oh, yeah, I think pursuit of research. It's not just over you, but I think higher education in general. I mean, pursuit of research. I'm a word graded when I was there research. I mean, I don't know whether anybody read the papers, but you sure how to put a list on how much money you brought in. I think that's pretty, pretty common right now.
And so you bring in more money. And I said, this is strange. You know, we're being paid rewarded for spending more money. Why don't we say, look, gee, I did all this interesting stuff. And I didn't spend very much of the taxpayer's money. I mean, it seemed to me that would make sense.
But it didn't work that way. So was the paper with over 10 and 72 is that sort of the beginning of the system's theory work?
Well, the systems theory work. First of all, in the computer modeling and ecosystems, I was doing ecosystems. So I was involved in systems.
And I was involved in some ecologist or limnologist, G. Evelyn Hutchinson. And there were a number of people, the beginning of ecology.
So I had used some of their work, met some of those people. And I was coming at it. But I began to realize that the rivers aren't the problem.
The trees aren't the problem. The fish aren't the problem. It's the human systems that are the problem.
So I began to realize this in the 70s, maybe even a little before that. And so what I started doing was studying human systems.
Now, if you're going to study human systems, you make a choice. I'm in a computer. So I can sit behind a computer. Of course, they didn't have the computer screens, but now, of course, they do.
Or I can actually get out in the organizational systems and see what's happening. I chose that second round. And that was actually a conscious choice. I'm going to collect experiences.
I'm not going to be sitting eventually once they got computer screens. I'm not going to be sitting behind a computer screen.
So I never had email on campus. Never. Okay. Okay. Never. I have some at home now. Will Gamble, you can interview him. I don't know if he will.
He didn't either. So we were probably the last ones. But I'm working with these computer systems. Now, when you work with these computer systems, there's a whole level of mathematics today that you can do.
So you can do a few linear dynamics emergence that you can't do with traditional mathematics. And you know, I can explain it. Take me about three for a minute. Explain it.
Because I have to explain differential equations. But basically, you couldn't solve the equations. And what do you do with differential equations? You start out with initial condition. You tell the rates of change and then you can make a prediction.
But with certain equations, nonlinear, particularly if they're say three dimensional. So you're going to see in space, you know, what the predictions are.
You end up with the things going around like this. It's called chaos. And you end up with a essentially the world is just not that predictable. And then you're throwing complexity.
And so over to the night were onto that 72. If you look up the references, one of them, I think the title had one plus one does not equal to that is the whole cannot be reduced to the sum of the parts.
And the other one was a paper by Warren Weaver that basically said science doesn't know does not know how to deal with problems of organized complexity.
So I was into the math. Because with the digital computer, you can approximate the solution to equations that you cannot solve.
So you don't solve them. You get finite difference numerical methods, approximations. That's what all the computer simulations are doing now. They don't solve the equations like they do in differential equations. They can't even come close.
But the nonlinear behave in weird ways. I mean, the nonlinear world is bizarre and it's only bizarre because for several hundred years, we've been taught to think linearly.
And when you're taught to think linearly, then when something nonlinear comes up, it seems bizarre. So I would meet with a guy, John Goldman.
He'd never get a chance to be a good one to interview. He was a campus minister here. And the best description of John is he's a medieval monk transported by a time machine.
So he'd never pass through the analytical age of say Newton and Galileo, the analysis breaking it down into parts. He thought holistically, you know, and he didn't have any trouble with this.
We had these discussions for years. For students, we just common people would come and we'd have these discussions.
And so the nonlinear world is a strange world. It's a world that requires you to think more with the right hemisphere of your brain.
Ian McGillcrest has a great video. People should look that up. The divided brain. And he says the left hemisphere is sequential linear. And we have become dominated by left brain thinking.
I think that's true. And he describes what would happen, what kind of organization would you get if it was dominated by left hemisphere? And he describes, and as far as I'm concerned, it's a university.
So the right hemisphere system, the world is so amazing. There's things emerge. And anyhow, that's the stuff I got into. But I wanted to get into it from a human perspective, big organizations.
I didn't want to stay in the mathematical modeling. I kept teaching. I had to make a living. I kept teaching the computer modeling. And I enjoyed it. I enjoyed teaching.
But when I teach, even engineering mechanics, I almost never brought in notes. The class almost never interact with the students. And the best classes occurred when the course, the class went in the direction that I didn't even anticipate.
And I just got to keep my life. And then the eyes light up when they get something. It's great.
It strikes me that you're placing a imperative on getting away from the computer screen and getting out and interacting with people. It falls the same while your father took it.
Yeah, I think that's probably true. He really did. He majored in physics, which at that time, physics. I mean, because physics, that time was going through a huge change.
And I brought him when he retired a pendulum and it has several magnets. So it's nonlinear. And it doesn't just swing back and forth. It just goes in this.
And when he looked at that, his eyes lit up and he just laughed and he says, that would have driven my professors crazy.
Yeah, I did that. It also sounds like there's a divergence between the curriculum that you're teaching or being compelled to teach in your research interests.
Oh, I have an opposite direction.
If I take my career at Oregon State, I can put all my accomplishments in two piles.
A, that got me promotion and tenure. This full professor tenure, all the rest of this.
A, right over here.
Pile B over here didn't go anywhere within your organization.
Or, you know, not very, not very far. The most important pile is B. You can throw out all the rest.
Now, I learned a lot by, say, teaching engineering mechanics. And you learn a lot, for example, in mechanics courses, the way we teach the math isn't that important.
You have to teach students how to sketch. Make a sketch. It's called a free body diagram. Ask any student who's taking it, you have to draw it.
So, how do you make a sketch? How do you think? How do you, how do you do that?
And you engage the students in that, you know, making the simple sketches.
So, when I went to study human systems, I'm going to make sketches.
Because, you see, a sketch is two-dimensional.
Okay? You know, it goes two-dimensional sketch.
Now, you can make a three-dimensional. That's, that's, it's not too hard to go to three-dimensional.
But going from one dimension, which is a written text, to two dimensions is a huge difference.
It's, it's just a huge difference. I mean, you, you can talk about something as perpendicular in two dimensions.
And that means this dimension cannot be reduced to this dimension. They're orthogonal.
In one-dimensional lines of reasoning, you can't do that. I mean, you can sort of say it, but it just, you don't see it.
So, the average, or typical book is what? About a half mile long. It's all one line. It's only arranged on pages for convenience.
And so, that shapes the way we think. We think in lines. And, and the world does not behave in lines.
The world is much more in this way. Now, if you go on a construction site, I learned this my first job.
They give you a set of specs, all lines written, and a set of drawings. I almost never looked at the specs.
I was all over those drawings. And if you go out on the construction site, watch construction on campus.
And you'll see people using body language. You'll see them taking out diagrams. They're not sitting around studying texts.
Professors do that. They could never build a building like that.
Well, I'm wondering if the system's theory, I mean, my impression anyway, it could be wrong about this, but it was sort of kind of the spine of your work in them.
And that went off in a lot of different kind of more topical directions or kind of current events, e-types, directions. Is that true?
Well, my work, I finally, a lot of the work in systems now is going highly sophisticated mathematics. And the study of emergence, for example, one of the best people of biology is Stuart Kaufman.
And he's done randomized Boolean networks. He did some things that's mathematical. And it's pretty good. So, you know, I've done some of that.
But I go, what's the point in all the math? I mean, if we're trying to understand the world that people are living in, then we ought to be able to communicate to them.
Because they know more about that world than we do. So, what I do is I make sketches.
And you make sketches. And now I'll do like ten statements on a sketch. And simple statements connected by arrows. So they loop.
And I'll get people, if I can get them to read it, the people who read it and I go, you just describe my life. This is what's going on.
So, one of them that I did was how information gets distorted in organizations. The classic example explanation we give is blame.
Look at the Veterans Administration. Okay, information was distorted. So, what do they do? They fire Eric Shinseki.
I mean, he's got to be one of the most honest straightforward guys you can imagine. I mean, he's an honorable person. And I mean that, in the best sense of the word.
And you listen to Congress and there, everybody's blaming everybody. So, what I did is I made a simple sketch. And how organization is a system.
And it provides a context within which everybody finds reasons to behave in their own particular way. But the system is a whole distorts information. Okay, that's what I do.
And that everybody inside of it has a good reason. And they're ordinary people like us. So I've done that.
I did a video about the original one in the late 70s. And first I didn't publish it but the model sort of circulated. People would send me. I got a zero ox of a zero ox. Can you send me a copy?
So then in 86 I think it was the shuttle blew up and
I'm watching television and I see Richard Feynman and
He's trying to explain what's going on on echo. He's describing my model. I never studied NASA
So I send them a copy of the diagram and this table and I didn't know he was dying a stomach cancer
I think was not a cancer at the time. I
Wish I would have I would have
Thank them. You know, so if you want to thank someone thank him quick
When they die he can't
I'll do it now. Thanks, Richard
Okay, and he read it and he wrote me back this letter and
He says I read this table and I'm amazed
Perfect prediction. No, I don't use perfect prediction
But if you're Richard Feynman, you can use Richard, you know, you can use perfect prediction
And he says I didn't realize that NASA was part of a general phenomena
Technically if I said that we say that's a grammatical era a phenomena if Richard Feynman says it it's brilliant
Okay, so then I started publishing it now next month August
I'll be going to Quebec City for the American Fisheries Society to present this model
Okay, and I got to figure out how to do it on a PowerPoint now because there's going to be 2500 people and I've got
half an hour so that that's a little I like to interact but you don't interact with 2500 people
So anyhow, I draw these models and when people can understand them and they see it
Then they can start telling you because they know more about the experience in the world and I do
They can start telling you and to a large extent what I'm doing is I'm providing an alternative to blame
Looking at these larger systems
Now it's consistent with a lot of the mathematics that's going on it's just that
You can experience it in life
And if the world is non-linear and emerging we are experiencing it because we have to open up our eyes
When one looks at sort of an abstract of your Vita there are
There are issues there mostly in the past now and I'm wondering if what you've just described as if these are examples of it
Having been that model haven't been applied in the past of things like space-based weaponry
Yeah, I will see I
That's an interesting I
About the 1980s
Some were 1980s. I was really getting frustrated with the environmental because you know
That's about the time that they started the global warming we will make predictive models and
Scientists may say well, we really weren't no, no, that's the way the objectives were written
I went back and looked at the original documents and we'll develop predictive models and I said now you know
I just you know so I got frustrated so I wanted to learn more about
Large-scale computer systems and that cannot I understand organizations by just observing so I went and I spent six years
Ronald Reagan Star Wars program and I had no funding
so I could go to the meetings and I didn't have to hustle any money and
Oh, you go to these meetings and you know these consultants there. They're always have to hustle money and
And so I could ask these these questions and I said I want to see if I can as a citizen if I can
Find something make a contribution here to something that they don't see and I did finds I did I could and
That's a whole other story and
Involves some interesting characters including Richard Cheney who was Secretary Defense at the time
So and Richard Garwin who designed the hydrogen bomb interesting really interesting guy
So I met some interesting people and I did some interesting things but I was mainly interested in the human systems and how
And then the large scale technological ones and how you we can lose control. I mean the control is sort of
often in illusion
You referenced earlier John Connor and Westminster House and the local environmental movement you want to talk more about him and in that period of time
Yeah, John Connor was a campus minister
He had been a minister in Mexico. Turns out he I found out years later that he
He moved my cousin in Raton. I think it was Raton in Mexico and
Anyhow John was
Was very tall and I had this long beard and
He'd he just would raise all sorts of questions. He raised all sorts of questions. He'd just be bouncing around and
he sort of stir up the pot and
We at that particular time
There was a whole national movement
were
Theology or mainline churches
With challenging higher education. There's a book on it Douglas Sloan from Columbia University. It's called faith in knowledge and
Probably out of print now, but it's very good book and they they were challenging higher education
And what Sloan writes about is everyone on for about two decades and Eisenhower's warning is sort of right in the middle of that
So there was a time in there where where people are
Looking at the problems of technology
Yes, it has good things what we have to recognize as limitations to there was sort of this attitude
So John played a key role in that and he was
Mainly the facilitator of he became moderator of the
Presbyterian Church which is I guess their highest position
and
He he would
You know, he did a lot of interesting things, but for me
It was like he was sort of at the focal point of a
Center of the whirlwind
We're all interesting things were happening
and
So that was very important time and there were concepts that came up then
Very very important
I wrote a paper
published it
2006 on evil
Well, this was a
It's a secular germ. I mean it's it's on emergency levels the title of it and I
used concepts from
Theology in there and no one no one raised any concern was you know
They were helping us to understand this this phenomena and basically I was saying that
Evil large patterns emerge and ordinary people like you and I get caught up within them and
In biblical language that would be bondage and blindness
you're caught up within it and
You can't transcend it
The context the system that that you're caught up within and
Harble things could be done and the example I use was a Soviet biological warfare system and
Harble horrible things and by some tough scientists
So scientists can get caught up in it just like anybody else
Anyhow that you know that probably has goes back in some ways to John Connor
It's interesting how often you've been working with church groups
I'm on the French is the French church groups. I you know, I I don't go regularly to
services
They're see part of it. I'm studying models well
I learned models as a kid they were called parables a
Parable is a model all models are simplifications and
What they do is help to clarify some matters of importance not all and they expose their limitations
Okay, so a parable is a story and what you do is you get engaged in the power you learn
And as you're
Going through life you begin ah you mean to see something and
That's what the purpose of a good model really is
That you play with it you engage and then it allows you to become aware of something
And it's very different than having a big computer that no one knows what it's doing and it spits out data
So in that sense what I was involved in was
Had its roots they're in parables, but also in engineering
You know
Scientists act like all this stuff that we build here all this stuff comes out of science
Okay, and
I would say yes, but I taught engineering mechanics this is Newtonian mechanics when engineers build
Like the buildings on campus just go watch them. They're amazing. They build them on campus
We also use safety factors
And we don't talk about students don't know about this and word safety factors come from they come from confession and repentance
Now confession and repentance is an amyle awful. It's not self-blame. It means you've done something and there's a failure
What are you gonna do?
You admit to the failure and you change your ways and
That's how you learn that's how you learn how to ride a bike
You don't study bicycle riding the theory of bicycle riding and pass a quiz a multiple grade
You know a multiple choice quiz and say now I'm a bike rider you get on it and you fall down
That's how life is and so in engineering civil engineering in particular if you look at the history
You see all these pictures of bridges that fell down you'd be gonna say what what's going on here? That's how we learn and
There's a historian
Engineering and he has some statements. He I read one the other day behind every almost every success is a history of failure something like this
Well, that's probably pretty good theology too
So there's been a whole part it's not about belief systems
And even churches get that wrong
You know the word belief is a modern word you know the word religion even I mean
It didn't you know it's a new word. I mean new in the last 700 years as a system of beliefs. It just doesn't make sense
So what you learn were stories and
Powerboats and you went out into the world and you made mistakes guess what?
So that's how you learn so
When I come back to some stuff that I learned in church and stuff that I learned in
engineering and stuff that I
Learn in environment
There are some common themes
Now what's absent is some of this foolishness like intelligent design or things like this and this this this is just a big distraction
I mean
I mean John Connor had no problem with evolution my father didn't now maybe his father maybe did but a lot of people did things change
So I've sort of been on the fringe of some
some I
Guess you call theological insights
That's pretty cool. There's some interesting ones and
They're not about belief systems and one of one of the things you find now, for example is
how
Buddhism and Christianity have
Parts of it just sort of come together and rediscovered each other and you take a guy like Richard Ruror who's a
Franciscan Catholic and
He will talk about the Dalai Lama
I mean this is like
The boxes we put people in it just doesn't make sense
Yeah
Tell me about the swallowed camel club. Oh the swallowed camel club. Okay. Okay the swallowed camel club
We had a group that this is spontaneously
Many years ago
First of the library and we were making almost too much noise and and
So we so we started meeting over at
St. Anson's is a Piscobo campus ministry because John Connor our time John Goldman was John Goldman and he's the guy that's this medieval monk and
We were
people were we'd raise certain questions and say I
Say well, are you getting this in your classes?
So if you really want to find out what's being taught you have to ask the students
Ask the students so this stuff on complexity and all the rest these big scale systems
Those you know, they're not addressing all things not really not in a way that registers with the students
I mean the student okay
So we've had these discussions so what are we gonna call our group?
Well, there's an ancient criticism of
University professors
You blind guides you strain out a net and swallow a camel
Okay, it's gospel St Matthew, okay, and it's right hemisphere
It's got a metaphor blind guide you strain out a net swallow a camel
Three metaphors it that's the right and and he puts them together in irony and humor and
Yet people go yeah, so obviously a camel is not the sum of a lot of little nets
So it's not linear so anyhow we we would laugh and sort of the joke we call it the small camel club and
We're not meeting this summer and
It's it's going on pretty strong the last several months though. We've
You know, we've sort of dropped off in part of it. I've been working on some other stuff and
Part John Goldman has retired
Piscillate churches going through some changes. So I'm not sure where it's gonna go
But it has gone on for years and there's still I got a email list of 30 40 people who would
belong to it
I send it out
Did you have any contact with Catherine Jeffers?
Story yeah, a little bit of contact with Catherine Jeffers. Sure
And Dick Shore he was a math master husband and non-linear
Dynamics but not much on this not not much on this
She's done a you know an outstanding job and certainly on making the piss I'm not a pissing paling
But making the
Gays and Lesbians and she's really done that and had to
Fight some battles and she does it very very graciously very graciously. I
Would say I'd love to get she also has a PhD in oceanography
I would also be fun to have in conversation with
Marcus Borg and I believe on Marcus Borg
Because I would be a little more questioning of science than I think they are. It's not that science is back
It's just that
There's a lot of specialization and a lot of claims
Those wonderful things
But not everything
And
We could have an interesting discussion
I want to ask you about a couple kind of bullet points from your beta the past research interests that I think have
Particular book ability to people in this state the first one is an issue that's been important to folks
My set of state needs an organ that's destruction of chemical weapons. Oh, yeah
That's an interesting story
So I got invited on this one. I actually got paid for this this one
You know I'm not a whole lot, but a lot of the work I did I didn't get paid for it
And I make my living teaching
The United States had millions of
Literally millions and millions of chemical munitions stored all over
And I mean they say their weapons, but most of them are not usable and one of them for example the M55 rocket
They made half a million of it. It's about a seven foot rocket
six-semin
And it's not guided and they don't even have launchers and the thing I think tends to go like this
So they got all these these rockets. Well, what are you gonna do with them?
And they got they have the warheads with the
chemical agent
inside of it
So you've got like a liquid and you've got a birch there because it's an aerosol
So I'm not really a gas and then you got all the booster rocket and they've riveted
The the warheads on so they can't just unscrew them
So they have to get rid of them. So I was part of a
Independent team to review the risk analysis
and
Because they want to know whether they should ship off site or
Historic on site and
incineration all the rest of this
Well one of the things I looked at was the M55 rocket and they had these
big steel insulated containers to transport them in
hey
And they had on wood pallets
So I don't know they might have had 15 on a pallet and two pallets might 30 so they you know 15 or 30 inside when these big
And they had tests so they could drop it from 20 feet
And if there's a fire could insulate
They went through all these accident scenarios
Well the way they do risk analysis is they break it down into different little what's the probability of this
Assign somebody this job what's the probability of this and they put them all together to find the probability
Of an accident occurring which requires maybe three or four or five different things happening
Okay, so it's a low probability
And they a lot of this stuff to have to pull out in the air like what's the probability of an airplane crashing into one of these
Igles or the storage bins well they have to figure out how many planes crashing and pulling out of the air
So the one I came up with is
Okay, what happens to the rockets if there is a train wreck
Well, don't worry is the word ahead
You know we checked the warhead on this thing and well and
Worried won't go off. I said, I'm not worried about that
What do you worry about? I'm worried about the rocket igniting
Inside
And it turns out that when they set up the system
They didn't put a box for that
so
Oh, that won't happen that won't happen that's they go that that won't happen
So you go to meeting and when they say oh that won't happen
Wait for the coffee break wait for the coffee break because then somebody comes up
Why don't you go check? I've heard this they say this
So anyhow, I end up in Toelle, Utah
and they're gonna go in on a tour
Of the incineration
But you have to word cast mask and they wouldn't mean to shave my beard and say I don't want to shave my beard
So we'll leave you out here. We'll just leave you with this guy
That's good. They leave you with somebody
This guy tests these these warheads
very ingenious design of the warhead
You know a fuse the fuse
but in the process I learned
that
But I was concerned is
Inside the if you have a crash
In all these rockets start smashing around
Then you take steel and you bend it
It gives off heat
So is it possible that in the twisting of the metal
You'll get enough heat to ignite the rocket because all the rocket really is is solid booster inside a steel tube
And is a slow explosion
The gas goes out the bottom
So
So I had done some calculations rough calculations
How much heat would be given off the punctured steel casing
And then how much temperature would rise in the steel right around it
And compared that to the ignition temperature of the rocket and
It was higher
So
If you would say oh there's no data on that
Well they say there's no data just
Sort of you know that may be
You know we've never seen the data or we've never collected the data or it doesn't mean that
There shouldn't be
Anyhow I find out that to this guy and I get the field notes
That they test these rockets by dropping
20 them
And three of them ignited
Three of them ignited
And I heard some stories about them trying to test the warhead
You know so they get a guy to shoot a rifle at the warhead
And sometimes he misses and hits the rocket and shivers
The rocket takes off
But they didn't have a box to put this in
So they get the number
Out of 20 so you get a probability
3 out of 20
He is like
3 by 20 and I said I've seen that number before
Because I go through all these calculations sheets
And I come and I find that number and they say all that's the probability of
A warhead going out my pocket police
It gives a reference. I look up this reference
And what happened is everybody started referencing everybody else and what started out as a rocket ignition
Ended up as the warhead
Got on
Okay
And of course if it's the rocket igniting
And there's 15 or 30 other rockets inside a steel container
You've got a bomb
Because they can only hold like three rockets igniting
So we pointed out that to them
So that was that was kind of interesting because
It illustrates that
The science that gets done
Depends to a large extent on how the organization
Of it is structured and funded
And if everybody says gee that's an interesting idea, but it's not my job
That means it's not being done
Everybody has a good reason why they're not doing it
But what happens is
The organizational structure in a sense can
And
Direct us
Ask certain questions and not do other questions
And then when those questions come up
occasionally
People can just dismiss us on my job
So we better change the organization. That's not my job. The organization is too big. I can't change it
And so what happens is the problems continue
Now fortunately they've managed to get rid of all the M 55 rockets
They did not transport them. So we got the right decision. You know, we we brought that and
how much of my
Response that we wrote it up and how much of it survived through the bureaucratic process some of it did some of it didn't so
I don't know but it was fascinating
I learned a lot about risk analysis
So an organizational structure
So they're they're doing a good job and I mean they had to get incinerated because these these rockets
They put a stabilizer in them, but if that stabilizer
Degrades and they think it does I mean those rockets go off
And they're all stored together. That's not that's not good
They had literally millions of millions of
Initial so when you read in the paper of the Soviet Union and the United States
arguing
About who's you know have the weapons and so forth
What they should have been saying was here you take him. No, you take him. No, I don't want him you take him
I mean they were they were billion dollar problem
Okay, potential disaster
and
Yeah, that was interesting. Yeah, so what other bullet?
I want to ask about salmon the idea of salmon parks. Oh, yeah salmon
Well, I've worked a lot with fisheries biologist and largely because once I started studying these human systems
I think it I didn't get research grants so I don't have travel money. So salmon's a local woman
We had some very fine people here
And salmon
So the American fisheries society back in
2005 they published it in 2006, but somewhere before then they basically said
We've been trying we've been trying to protect wild salmon and
We spent billions of dollars and it's not working
So we want to select 33 people from out the country and even maybe outside the country
But but mainly
Canada and the United States
Northwest
What would you do? So totally free to say what would you do?
And so I was one
So Bob Lacky he's he's over there in political science and fisheries. He was he was the
Director and Denise Locke
I was on it and
so
So Bob so they framed the problem
The problem is how do we have significant numbers of wild salmon by the year 2100 and then he had four policy
guides and one of them
Four policy drivers
okay
Something right name
and one of them was
People are going to have to change their preferences
Or their values or preferences
So I went through the whole thing and I basically
concluded that the way they framed the problem you can't sell the problem
Okay, we're not gonna sell
And the besides the problem numbers of wild salmon that's not the real problem the problem is what kind of world do we want to leave
future generations
And the whole business about preferences I said no we're gonna get outcomes that no one prefers
so
So what I did is I
Reframed the problem now that's kind of like you're being given a test
And you go in and you decide I can't answer this question so I'm gonna change the question and I'm supposed to do that
So but I did it and I got to give them credit they kept the paper in there
so
Basically what I had to do is I thought it would be real easy. I'll just say wild salmon national park
That's what we need
But I in order to do that I had to challenge all the ways that we're thinking which are linear ways of thinking
Now wild salmon national park is doable
We have all sorts of agencies doing all sorts of things like the Corps of Engineers sits mitigation sites
We don't even know where they are
Okay, if you pull that money together and you could buy up
Particularly high flood prone areas which are the best habitats all way throughout the whole north west
And you would have a distributed wild salmon national park
Okay, even through cities they people want their waterfronts
So you know it wouldn't be
total of natural systems, but and there are a whole sorts of flood zones and and
You look at the land of river and you see all these different twists and turns and
The farmers have trouble farming there because they flood
Well, plan all these weeds, but they call weeds which
And biologists called in natural floor. Okay, it's really funny
And if you look at the people who are studying floods and they map out high flood prone areas and
Gee, we got to prevent development do something about that
And then you go over to the wildlife biologist and take their maps of ideal habitat and they almost overlap
So it's a no-brainer, okay
Why don't we just buy some of this land and and and pay the people
You know not to build there rather than putting concrete or
Rock rip wrap along the banks because it made a road
So I went through a whole bunch of those things and I basically found that
Yeah, we could have a wild salmon national park
Wait, and it would run right through different parts of the whole Pacific Northwest
and
Try and let the salmon come back and let the salmon guys
The biggest resistance seemed to come from the science and
It wasn't about the science everybody agreed we have to protect habitat
But they would say nobody's going to support that people don't prefer that
Well
Took that is it how do you know?
Okay
First it's not about preferences
They amount of money
It's pittance I took the compared the the whole
National Park budget for that year
So I don't know
I may get the numbers wrong but five billion let's just say yeah, okay
And then I compared the bonuses given to Goldman Sachs one bank is like 20 billion
Okay as much big here's here's the national park the whole national marks here's the here's the
bonuses given to Goldman Sachs the year before the whole system crashed
Okay, I don't think the people even in Goldman Sachs think that that's makes sense
But you say oh people won't and then the same year
That we put finally published this
PBS did a special
American national parks America's best idea
So
Basically, I conclude that the reason we don't have that is because the institutions have framed the problem in pieces
So everybody can say it's not my job
And then everybody can blame everybody else
And then everybody can focus on their little job
Now there is a guy you could be interesting to interview
I don't know
David Lane because he did his PhD dissertation on brief framing
And he used the same in 2100
as his test case
And he's got brilliant idea
he basically said
If if there are environmental problems that we have not been able to solve we've probably framed the problem in the wrong way
It's like if I give an exam question to my engineering students
And at the end of the exam period all my smart students are still trying to solve the problem. I'm in trouble
Because I frame the problem in a way they can't solve
So what he wanted to do is to look back over the history and find
reframings
Because we will lose them because the institutions frame the problem in a particular way
So if someone comes along and reframes it
Everybody may say it's a good idea but he gets lost in the institution
So he develops software to get indicators of reframing
And he could have a software search through with these indicators
To try to find a radical reframed and identify it and he used same in 2100 as an example
And his indicators go like this and then my paper came out like this. That's how I got to know
So he's working over there with
International students with English teaching English
I'm asking a couple more questions about OSU
Your your research interests in your contacts primary contacts. It seems we're pretty far field from
Traditional civil engineering
Did you ever feel isolated or like a man about a home on some level?
Yeah, you do sometimes the hardest thing over the years
People act like well if you do this, you know, somebody's gonna fire you then that's not the problem
I you know, I never had the problem now. I I was fortunate
because
Maybe because of my family but I could teach and
So I get real high course evaluations. So that sort of protected me
And because if you're not bringing in research dollars
It's gonna be pretty hard to survive
But I was able to do that. So there's some interesting stories on that
Well, I'll tell you one story
Some of Columbia Root study history study
And guide Daniel Hancock and I were
Or some contractors for
I said this is a dangerous project. I only want to be a sub-country
For the the interactions the biophysical interactions house all this stuff interact
And so
We're looking at the project and they made all these grants and they're out there and
None of it's gonna interact because they're people are just doing their own thing
So we come up with a scheme which we
We develop hypothesis systems. I said we'll have an annual meeting and
Dan and I put up these hypothesis systems about a problem and
We'll present it to the the whole group and I said we'll follow the Bella cooking rule
Anybody who doesn't like it gets to do that the next time anybody who can play so then so you end up with these
You know everybody interacts and we end up with these hypothesis systems
And then you reallocate the funding based upon whether you're going to actually
Be able to address these hypotheses. So it's sort of a learning process
So there's a a an estoria there's going to be a workshop
there and
So the manager of the project
He says okay you will meet for the first half of the day and I'll do the second half of the day
Vice versa you'll do half a day. We'll do have so we said okay, so we prepared this for the citizens advisory group
And there are people in there who are fishermen and local people there. I mean they know a lot about the history
They know a lot more than I do
So we present this to them. Oh, when we get down there the manager says you do the whole day. I'm not gonna do anything
So I think he was thinking was gonna drop something on us
Actually, we say great
So we do the workshop and they loved it because these fishermen have I mean they they had ideas on this and we're sketching them out
And they said now we can be involved in in this and we can actually see you can come to these meetings and
so the meeting ends and
We go out to eat managers there and I didn't realize we didn't pick up on his
We're usually pretty good at picking up on body language, but Dan and I are still talking we don't realize how angry he is
Because this means our approach
He has to reorganize the boxes and he's got them all lined up
and
I didn't realize how angry he was until we're eating
And all of a sudden he loses it jumps up and throws his briefcase
So which I catch and throw it back at him and he storms out well
Needless to say we didn't get funded
uh
But the whole project crashed
But the interesting part
Is apparently if I remember right my promotion
Committee was meeting like the week before so on the record I had this grant
So
So I was able to squeak by I guess I don't know but I made it so
But now you were getting by a lost track of the question
How do I feel at Oregon state?
The hardest thing to deal with are the stone faces
You bring up an interesting idea
Something that you think is important and you get a plank
And
I noticed this when David Lane would go with me since you got the stone face
And I think what happens is I'm not sure what's really going on here
But people become so focused on their little field
That the grooves in their brain gets so deep that it just doesn't register
or they'll
They may say oh you'll just have to read our literature
Which is just it's just not there
So it's it's been sort of a lack of
Exciting discourse I think that that's probably been the hardest thing to do with that's and that that takes a toll
And there is a story on this
David and the life
Okay
David big the lie at the huge guy
No one wants to take him on so David shepherd boy comes up and says I'll take him on
So first thing he puts on the king's armor and he can't move
Okay, we put on a lot of armor. We can't move either like academic citations and references in the academic language and mathematical equations
You can't move
So he takes off the armor goes there picks up and gets some stones
And of course the story goes
Slice go live. I said yeah, but what about the other stones
They don't tell you that see they lead parts for years post-apfelant
So I'll tell you what happened to the other stones
This is the first stone
He missed
That's what life is about
You miss
So then
Second stone
This is well
He hit him made a really mad
Okay
Third stone
This is the one that's most painful
What's worse than hitting him and getting really mad
I don't know
Get it make your shot hit him right between the eyes. He doesn't even notice
And he says that really wears on for a long time
So I'm at the end of my talk, you know someone said someone who knew the story better. There's another stone
What yeah, there's a fourth one. What did that one do? I said I don't know
I don't know
So my wife is there and I just leave I come home
She goes back and she says I know what the fourth stone was
It's the holy rolling stone like a what
She put on this music and it was from
I'm TV show John of Arcadia or something that word God appears to people is
Is the janitor or somebody like this and it's like a holy rolling stone and I so I still don't get it
He says he dropped it and if he came the holy rolling stone for someone else to pick up
And that's a whoa that's cool
So
But anyhow the the painful part is often this is
Being seeing that there are some really big challenging problems and then
Just not being able to sustain this course. That's the hardest part
We've seen a lot of change at OSU and this is the season of change for the university as well. I'm warning
Be interested in your perspective. I'm kind of where it's where the university's come from where it's heading
Yeah
Well, they've done a very good job in the campus and landscaping. I think the campus and landscaping
Really remarkable
I think they've
Pretty much given up on the idea of
educating and alert and knowledgeable citizenry you have to have discourse in order to do this
I think they're really
I'm very close ties with industry
I think Rod Adams who was the
Dean of engineering very close ties in the industry. He's now I guess the vice president or something now
And it's not that that's bad, but it's sort of like it is unbalanced and there there has to be some other
role where the university does some unique things that no one else can do
And I think they've forgotten that and I think they're good people
Embrace good person
Steve Clark's good person
But what I find in the systems is
The systems of depth so the people were very successful in them in a sense become part of the system far more than they realize
They become not just in the system, but of the system
and
It's just too easy to start believing your own hype and that's sort of a danger
You need scouts. You need somebody
I used to tell presents
Custard's biggest mistake. It's a little big horn as he didn't listen to his scouts
And the scouts somebody who's not bucking for higher position
And the only time you really need a scout is to tell you something you don't want to hear
That you're going in the wrong direction. You don't need someone applauding the direction you're going in
Okay, and so I think there's there's an absence of scouts
They're out there. They're willing to do that and I consider myself a scout and
And I'm not a leader in the sense. I don't have lots of people following me and I'm not a follower
So I go out and explore and that's that's important
so
We are testing with
I'm always trying something but with one idea and
I'm working with Charlie Varys with former mayor and economist and court Smith and anthropologist
And it has to do with global warming and we have
Many many probably thousands
Other here is students from places particularly China coming here
Very conscientious man going back
That's a good
So the question is where they really learning when they come here
I mean this place blows their mind
This is totally different
And they're first of all they're wealthy little
Okay, so it's not you know
It's not the peasants coming from China
That I grew up with I mean bison pretty nice cars
And they're living in a place that in any place of the else in the world would be called car heaven
Corvallus I mean we talk about our parking promise. I mean compared to the rest of the world. This is nothing
So they're learning something like being here
And I think they're learning the wrong lessons
Okay, they're learning. This is how things are done and if they're in civil engineering they're probably being taught how to do it
So we came up with a proposal and
basically that
Oregon State University and the city of Corvallus in the canary
Would develop some of no car communities
Serve by rail line we have an existing rail line
That existing rail line goes north goes right through the middle of town goes through the southern end of the campus and right through a piece of property bigger than the campus
The university owns most of it and then further
Okay, you build a clustered no car
Community I don't know the scale you want to get a scale that is viable neighborhood scale
So that if you were building a mega city that would be the sort of scale in the neighborhood
Okay, so I don't know 1500
3000 something
and
What you do is you involve the students in the design of this and
In doing it we are telling them the way we have developed this has been a mistake
Okay, this cannot continue and we are going to do it for ourselves
We're not lecturing you that you are to do something that we've done
You know that you shouldn't do what we've done
What we're doing is we're asking for your help
The help sign a viable community here
In Carballes that would involve students involve faculty and some citizens from town
The rail line is all the way through there. It's already there
How could we use it what could be the way to do it and what we would do is
Involve the students in lessons learned they go look to all of the world what were the successes and failures?
There's a couple of cities in China that
Wants to get you that is pretty much a walkable city, but there's also some disasters in China
So you learn from those okay lessons learned
And then you get some of them to start building a virtual
Examples of this they can take towards
There there is a program where it's a construction program
But I don't know whether you're familiar. I'm not in the video gaming
But Atlantic had a magazine and of course it's an imaginary world
You know
Monsters and all the rest but they build stuff
Well, why not make a real one they have a hundred million
Participants in this thing that's more they're all the university students in the United States
Okay
So what you would do is you you make this part of their effort
And what they would do is to say you want to understand the local culture
It's this the university town we have a campus as some good examples
How can you build on the architectural success on the campus
So that when they went back they'd say what's the local culture?
How do we build on the success of that local culture? How do we do this?
No, we don't need to have automobiles and you can serve it in different ways and have viable communities
So anyhow, we've written up a proposal
so
One page both sides and then we've written a memo which we gave to Steve Clark
Okay, and I got whether it went anywhere, but we're gonna start
Spreading it out and we've been meeting on this for about a year now every week
Over the magic. So we're
Where it's gonna go? I don't know, but you know, it's doable
It's doable when you look at when you look at the satellite photographs if take a Google
Gold or whatever it is earth
You look around
It goes right and buy right by a parking garage. I mean how ironic
Right by a parking garage and then right on through
Piece of land you can have open space farm space all around it and
Then there's there's another one just near fuel it back up
And then you look at the sight of you the back of it is you know, it's about a half-bargaged spaces
mostly empty now
Anyhow that's that's that's some of the stuff we're working on
Well my last question for you is as you think about the future. Are you able to stay optimistic?
Okay, this is a good question
There's a big difference between optimism and hope
okay, and
There's a
Cornell West the theologian from the Hill
And he's black
And he says I cannot be optimistic, but I am eternally hopeful
Hope requires courage to act when doubt is warranted
Okay, now David Lane found that when he did a thesis and went I was in a class as honest class
David Lane presented that to that class
Their jaws dropped and they said why hasn't anybody told us that
So optimism
It's it's hard for me to just be optimistic
But optimism
Involves with the Buddhist call attachment you're attaching to the outcome
So you don't want to attach to the outcome
And I realize an engineering you know, you're supposed to attach to the outcome
But an engineer can't deal with big problems and deal with a lot of little ones
The little ones don't add that all little ones may be good, but they don't that doesn't mean that the whole is good
Okay, the world with linear that would make sense for the world with linear
I can be a great musician because I can play great notes on a grand piano
But when I add up all the notes it's terrible music
So the world is non-linear
so
I'm hopeful and I'm hopeful and
What you do is you don't attach to the outcomes and you you do something creative you try to make a contribution in there and
You don't
You know of course sometimes you feel bad if it doesn't work, but
I look back
And if I look at all the failures if you wanted to say they didn't go anywhere
now someone did
And if I had to do it over again, I do it the same way
So I have there's no regret so I guess if you approach you know, I'm 75 now you approach
That age and you don't have regrets and you say no, I wouldn't trade what I've done with anybody else. I know
That's pretty good
But if if I ask me okay, well, why don't you list all your accomplishments
No, I I know think that's the right question
Now again that gets to be some theological
that
In Cornell West hope is a courage to act when
doubt is warranted and then
Hope also comes as a gift freely get gift that's what I call grace
So he is I don't know I was gonna turn out, but I don't have to know
Okay, and the idea of prediction and control is just illusion. It's just just
Yeah, if you're building a cabin, maybe that's okay, but we're talking about the future of the earth and societies
Yeah, it's just just don't do that. So we need to tell that to the students
Our generation use of talent
Well, thank you very much. This has been a lot of fun and I appreciate you being so generous with your time and welcome to your home
Well, I I would again anybody who looks at this that the oral history is extremely important because there are a lot of things
That didn't make it into all the documents that they're studying
And they may be the important things it's kind of what
Sherlock Holmes dog that didn't bark
Okay, the stuff that you don't find
Why didn't you find it? Well, that can you learn a lot from that?
Okay, we do know we can okay, well good. I appreciate it. Thanks. Thank you